50 leopard tanks Gathering dust in a
warehouse near Brussels sold by the
Belgian Army to a private company at a
time when a new war in Europe seemed
Unthinkable now the owner wants to sell
them back for nearly 10 times the
original price maybe you can say I'm a
visionaire so no no there are other
countries there are still countries in
the world who have this leopard one
tanks so there's always possibility
either to sell spare parts or to sell
additional tanks while Ukraine is
fighting off a new Russian offensive his
tanks won't leave the warehouse anytime
soon A Promise by Western countries to
send two battalions of lapper 2 tanks
has yet to materialize the Netherlands
sold all its leopard two tanks years ago
we have bought Leo once so the the
previous version of the Leo 2 in larger
quantities they have to be refurbished
they have to be battle ready but they
will be provided to Ukraine not ready
before this offensive but we're we are
in the middle of the offensive and it's
going to go on uh so everybody including
industry is doing what they can to speed
it up the message here at NATO is to
produce more weapons and ammunition as
soon as possible meaning that an
industry that was killed back after the
Cold War should rapidly be brought back
into full action the alliance's
Secretary General has called it a battle
of logistics and the clear winner will
be the arms industry Nils duker who has
studied the arm straight for 20 years
warns against rushing into more
production of weapon systems without a
long-term security plan a lot of armed
forces in Europe are actually what we
would call Bonsai armies they look like
real armies they have the feel of an
army but in reality they're not able to
defend the country itself so I think it
would be much better if you would
actually invest more in cooperation
between European states with regard to
the military and defense and that way
the money that becomes available you can
actually invest in other issues that are
very important in creating eating a more
durable piece
all the weapons produced to be sent to
the front lines have only one aim he
says to negotiate a peace deal while
trying to make sure they won't fall into
the wrong hands after the war step fast
and Al Jazeera Brussels